المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
الوضع الميداني صعب لان الروس كان لديهم
الوقت لبناء دفاعات قويه وهذا ما جعل
حلفاء كييف يقررون امدادها بقنابل عنقوديه
وهو ما سيمكنها من اختراق تلك الدفاعات
على حد تعبيره اضاف ساك في لقاء مع
الجزيره ان القناه النيتو سيبحثون ملف
اوكرانيا في قمتهم المقبله
وستتلقى كييف دعوه خلال القمه للانضمام
للحلف بعد انتهاء الحرب
هذه ليست حربا ضد روسيا روسيا هي التي
بدات الحرب روسيا هي التي ترتكب الجرائم
والاعمال الارهابيه في اوكرانيا عده دول
من النيتو تدعم اوكرانيا في حربها المشروع
نريد تحرير ارضنا من هؤلاء المجرمي الحرب
هناك قمه للناتو في الايام المقبله
وستتلقى خلالها اوكرانيا دعوه للانضمام
للحلف بعد انتهاء الحرب